[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoy quiero hacer una confesión he
mantenido una doble vida por un lado
está
jose hándal el hombre de negocios
catedrático universitario y hasta
donante de la cruz roja por el otro lado
está
jh bográn
el escritor miembro de asociaciones
profesionales como de autores goes o la
international thriller riders uno con
una carrera profesional y otro como un
pasatiempo pero ese no era el plan
original de joven pensé que iba a
conquistar el mundo con mis historias y
cuando termine el colegio descubrí que
no había una carrera universitaria para
eso estaba letras o idiomas pero más
orientados a la docencia así que terminé
matriculado en esta universidad en la
siempre popular administración de
empresas
en mi primer año me acerqué a un
catedrático me gusta escribir le dije
que bueno me dijo él como escritor
latinoamericano tienes que seguir las
corrientes actuales escribe realismo
mágico como gabriel garcía márquez
escribe en contra de las transnacionales
como ramón amaya amador escribe
historias que muestren la inequidad del
hombre
pero a mí me gustaban las historias de
misterio de acción
entonces este profesor me dijo que
dejara de escribir niñerías y que mejor
escribiera la literatura
pero que es literatura bueno una novela
literaria es de un nivel muy alto con
palabras poco usuales y cuyo enfoque
principal es el lenguaje la belleza está
en el cómo contar la historia una novela
comercial por su parte sigue en
argumento y tiene un final bien definido
en este tipo de escritos el objetivo
principal es resolver o descubrir un
crimen es rescatar a una princesa o
puede ser un amor entre jóvenes
el lenguaje pasa a ser una herramienta
para contar la historia la mayoría de
los escritores hondureños le apuntan a
lo literario y hasta hace muy poco
entran en el género comercial
si lo comparamos con el cine podríamos
decir que las novelas literarias se
comparan a películas como la lista de
schindler o el discurso del rey son las
que generalmente se ganan el oscar a la
mejor película
mientras que entre las comerciales
tenemos cualquier película the avengers
de marvel o de la serie duro de matar
el punto es que yo quería escribir sobre
espías y ladrones y el profesor quería
que escribiera otros 100 años de soledad
me decepcione mucho
pensé que mis historias no valían la
pena y dejé de escribir por mucho tiempo
desarrollé una carrera en las maquilas y
me convertí en un ejecutivo de éxito
actualmente trabajo con una ong
internacional
cuando volví a escribir lo hice como un
pasatiempo
según la real academia española un
pasatiempo es una actividad en la que se
gasta un tiempo de ocio es decir es una
es una actividad en la que no esperamos
tener una remuneración económica o que
nos genere una ganancia todos tenemos un
pasatiempo un hobby algunos leen a otros
les gusta correr hay quienes coleccionan
estampillas postales los pasatiempos nos
dejan algo siempre leer nos da
conocimiento correr nos da salud y bueno
que nos puede dejar coleccionar
estampillas postales nos da felicidad y
esa es la mejor recompensa de un
pasatiempo la felicidad
como escribir ya era un pasatiempo ya no
tenía la presión por convertirme en un
escritor famoso o que mis novelas se
vendieran más que las de harry potter
así que me dediqué
a desarrollar el arte de escribir a
aprender cómo escribir
una de las cosas que aprendí puede
desarrollar las historias
capturar una idea es importante porque
es el punto de inicio de un proceso
creativo que termina en una novela o en
un cuento una manera de desarrollarlos
es contestando la pregunta qué pasaría
si
veamos algunos ejemplos
qué pasaría si un extraterrestre llega a
la tierra de niño y de grande quiere
salvar el planeta
así fue como surgió superman
qué pasaría si una mujer decide usar su
inteligencia para resolver crímenes
eso fue lo que hizo ágata christie con
su detective favorito la señora maple
en una ocasión mientras le daba de comer
a uno de mis hijos le cayó leche sobre
el labio formando un bigote yo le hice
la broma a mi esposa este parece el
nieto de adolfo hitler
y esa idea se convirtió en la novela
heredero del mal
heredero del mal este año será publicada
en inglés bajo el título eruptivo
escribo en inglés porque el género
comercial es muy popular en otros países
y mis historias han circulado a través
de varios países
en tres continentes bajo el seudónimo de
jh bográn he sido el escritor de cinco
novelas de series de televisión de
guiones para cine de columnas de opinión
en diarios y revistas
fui el primer escritor hondureño en
publicar un libro electrónico en el 2006
pero todo comenzó como un pasatiempo
a veces creemos que nuestros sueños son
imposibles y los matamos antes de
cumplirlos pero vean mi ejemplo este
pasatiempo este hobby se convirtió en
una carrera alterna ahora hasta me pagan
por escribir
espero que me crean porque jamás digo
mentiras sólo las escribo
[Aplausos]